Well, next up.
Inc. reports that Delta Airlines
is blocking out entire rows that can only be reserved
by groups of three or making it
more easy for families to sit together.
So if you're traveling alone and one of those seats is like,
"Sorry, you can't have it."
Now, if you're in a group or with a family,
you can actually book it out
because all of us who have families
know how hard that is to do.
Oh yeah.
But I will say a lot of my friends
who don't have families don't like this concept at all.
Well, listen, there is nothing more annoying
than when you you are traveling with somebody
and you can't get seats next to each other
and you have to do that dance of like,
"Oh excuse me, do you, do you mind a window seat?"
Or do you...
And then, right?
And then have you ever done that and someone said no.
And then you just stare at them the whole rest...
"You know what you did."
"I hope you're comfortable in that window seat."
(Drew cackling)
It's true, it's like if it doesn't go the right way,
it goes the wrong way.
Yeah, and have you heard of karma?
That's gonna come back to you.
I know, but some people like have real preferences.
They're like, "I wanna be on the aisle
because I have to pee every five minutes."
Or, "I like a window, I paid for a window."
I get it.
I will say...
How many people travel here with kids.
Oh, that sounds awful.
(audience laughing)
(laughing) That sounds so terrible.
And I love that.
I love otherhood.
I would, I now know motherhood.
So I'm in.
And it's my first choice.
But I love otherhood.
Wait, well, I'm telling you,
when you travel with kids and a little group,
it is so hard to find seats together.
You end up bothering that person almost every flight.
And it's awful.
So I like this from Delta.
I think it's cool.
And I think others should follow suit.
It's just a few rows.
Oh wait, can I ask you what otherhood is?
You just threw that out.
Like I'm supposed to know.
I'm now I'm looking up the dictionary.
Otherhood, otherhood.
What is it?
I call otherhood what you do if you don't have kids.
That Drew Barrymore, you're a genius.
Otherhood, did you make that up?
Yeah.
We'll copyright it, dear.
Copyright it.
Own it.
(audience applauding)
Hash a little circle R.
Well we got to send a quick thanks
out to the man and the brand
that's been hydrating us all here for the last two seasons.
We launched our show in a pandemic
and Jason Mamoa kindly helped sponsor our show
with Mananalu Water.
I actually do posts about this water all the time
because I'm so obsessed with it.
If you put these in the fridge,
the metal, it makes it like spa water.
Exactly.
And it's so good for the planet.
Thank you.
This is what we've been looking for.
I love you, Jason Mamoa.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)